so we're sort of looking forward to or
at least i am more so than i was looking
forward to the conventions to the
debates between donald trump and joe
biden which are scheduled starting in
the later part of september i believe
we're going to be covering all of them
live for sure
um one of the things that i've said is
that
if you are expecting that joe biden is
going to implode and he's going to just
be unable to get anything out and and so
on and so forth
you're probably going to be underwhelmed
and in fact one of the things that i've
been pointing to
were some of the expectations when the
democratic primary
was down to only bernie sanders and joe
biden you had a bunch of people on the
right and even some people on the left
kind of in the pro-bernie crowd who were
saying
biden something's wrong with biden
biden's going to be unable
to keep it together biden's going to be
unable to put together a coherent
sentence
and of course joe biden did fine in the
debate against
bernie sanders now it is true that the
subject matter
because it was heavily coronavirus based
uh
probably helped biden uh in in some
sense
but if you were expecting biden to be
unable to put together a sentence you
certainly were disappointed
and i've made the same prediction about
the debates with donald trump you have
people including
like don jr and others on the right who
are pushing the biden dementia
narrative who are claiming that joe
biden is barely going to know where he
is in a debate
with donald trump and i just don't think
that's going to be the case
now in advance of this donald trump has
now started floating the idea
that maybe the reason joe biden was able
to hold it together in his one-on-one
debate with bernie sanders was that
joe biden was on some kind of drug
presumably some kind of stimulant
now what is amazing to me about this
is that this is exactly the speculation
about donald trump
the degree of projection from donald
trump and republicans if you look at the
rnc
this week accusing the democratic party
and the dnc of everything which
they have been doing this week accusing
the dnc
of merely criticizing trump during their
convention
well all they've been doing is
criticizing joe biden accusing the dnc
of not talking about policy during their
convention
the republicans have not talked about
any policy during their convention
and now after years of speculation that
donald trump you know we've we've
identified
upper trump and downer trump upper trump
sometimes shows up at events
sweaty speaking in a sort of manic way
uh dilated pupils even in front of
bright
lighting sniffing uh glitching etc and
then sometimes it's a downer trump that
shows up
and you know the the sort of casual
speculation is is it amphetamines when
it's upper trump
is it benzos when it's down or trump is
it some combination of both
okay whatever now by trump says
he wants drug tests before the debates
because he believes joe biden may have
been on something
during his debate with bernie sanders
here's the video
what nobody thought is that he was even
going to win
because he had debate performances was
so bad you know
frankly his best performance was against
bernie
we're going to call for a drug test by
the way because his best performance
was against bernie it wasn't that he was
winston churchill because he wasn't but
he
it was a normal boring debate you know
nothing amazing happened and
and we are going to call for a drug test
because there's no way you can't do that
well i don't know how he could have been
so incompetent
in his debate performances and then all
of a sudden be okay against bernie
i don't mean he was good or greater i
just mean he was a
normal boring debate it was nothing you
understand he got through it
well frankly i thought he he was you
know they were even
more or less right and most people
didn't think
and so they did something they did
something there was no way because i
watched his debates against
kamala who's another one that's a beauty
she's she's if you go by the polls
she started high and she ended low
that's usually not a good sign right as
far as somebody that you pick
but against elizabeth warren they ripped
her apart
so uh there there's a few different
thoughts here first of all on the facts
should candidates be drug tested before
debates
i don't really think so to be perfectly
frank now
i think if you want to step back and say
we need to look at
more requirements to be president of the
united states
i think it's legally difficult the one
that for me would be a higher priority
than a drug test would be an actual
proper
cognitive test than a neuro psyche eval
like dr
bandy lee talked to us about a couple of
weeks ago
but maybe the country would decide
presidents shouldn't be using drugs
and thus presidential candidates should
be tested for drugs
the idea of a drug test before a debate
is not particularly interesting to me
but the most
interesting part of it is that it is
trump who many have suspected
of abusing whether it's amphetamines or
some other type of upper and again it's
all speculative but
the idea that now trump is saying biden
should be tested
what i hear is projection the constant
projection from donald trump of the last
four years has trained me to think
if trump is pointing to something if
trump is raising the idea
if it occurs to trump that biden's
performance may have been enhanced
by some kind of uh uh stimulant or
something else it seems implicit that
trump is talking about stimulants
i immediately go to is trump thinking
about that because it applies to him
and i'm curious to hear what you think
about this
one of our sponsors today is surf shark
a premium
vpn service packed with a ton of useful
features
giving my audience 85
off a two-year plan this is under two
bucks a month
plus you'll get three extra months for
free
it's 2020. if you're not using a vpn you
should really start
online government surveillance is a
problem internet providers can sell your
internet history
big tech companies track what you do
online you can protect yourself against
all of this just by using a vpn and the
one i use is
surf shark because it comes with all
kinds of special features it's a company
you can trust with your online privacy
surfshark
hides your ip address removes ads
protects you from
malware and phishing attempts and it
allows you to stream content
that's only available in other countries
you can install surfshark on unlimited
devices
and surfshark never monitors or logs
your internet activity
surfshark is giving my audience 85 off a
two-year plan which comes out to
less than two bucks a month plus you'll
get three extra months for free
go to surfshark.deals
pacman the link is right underneath this
video